a huge turnout expected at lake mead  this weekend with the continuing  decrease in water levels  it is causing some concern for boaters  the level has dropped below  1075 feet so to put that into  perspective  the last time the lake was above sea  level was more than 20 years ago  at 1220 feet greg hauberger  chief of staff at lake mead says boaters  should check the status of certain ramps  before they launch  there's still a lot of water out there  it is a significant decrease  but there's still a lot of access points  available and we just want to remind  people there might be a little bit of a  longer wait  due to the decreased number of launch  ramps available this weekend  as of now the only ramp that is set to  be closed is hemingway harbor but  boulder harbor  and colville bay will all have multiple  lanes open  for you